people sick of my friends on Facebook we
are ready to continue and our next
speaker is fellow short will talk bring
us back down to earth about the failure
okay so if that's in the first trailer
of projects are okay so I'm going to
talk to you we all heard about the
amazing abilities of I'm going to talk
about what does it work
now this these failures do not stem from
just wanting to destroy the party I'm
using deep learning all the time we work
on autonomous driving I have some videos
but I don't know [ __ ] the work okay so
let's see these are our detection in
Paris the Ramadan of the Triomphe so
they call Jake is the salt based on
deterring
they show the difficulty detection in a
under different light conditions
if clean carpet is a reflection of what
we call the free space this is where we
can go as you can see there is aa it's
very difficult to understand the
difference between the road and say
what's going on here
potential still illumine burning so this
is a way from Jordan to Tel Aviv the car
glass itself and I'm sitting behind the
driver sitting there taking field using
my smartphone you can see the little
device provide you can get again stood
alone during wintertime so as you can
see we can do a lot of things it's not
only supervised learning this is a
result of a double emerge situations
cars coming from the right hand from the
left hand needs to go to the left some
needs to go to the right of the red cars
need to go to the right the white cars
need to go to the left what you see here
is reinforcement learning again using
deep learning as a function of oxidation
there is a complete symmetry between the
cars so they should negotiate learn how
to negotiate with each other
and if you want to know why this is
needed so this is around about next to
my house you can see it's the same
scenario there is double merge if it
will if they were found you you can hear
them shouting let's see it again so when
when we when we are in the complexity of
the task what is going on and this is
nothing it should negotiate with others
as well as gives the right-of-way to cow
if you can see the cow in the middle
okay
and deep learning is really amazing some
of us made money out of it but this talk
is about the faded of deep learning so
what I want to show here is that simple
plot that simple from the problems where
standard algorithms for different either
does not work well or does not work at
all
in the main message that I would like to
convey that we still need for the
knowledge we still not need to
understand what we are doing we may need
to rethink about what supervision we are
giving to the algorithm at least the
current moment the deep learning
algorithm does not solve everything and
I would like to try to give intuition
about when and why the editing doesn't
work I didn't I forgot to mention
because of the projectors this is a
joint work with partial nail we're
sitting here in sama student of mine ok
so I'm going to present for families of
five trailers it comes from example the
first example is piecewise linear curves
then we will talk about flat activations
end-to-end training which is very very
popular but I will show that it can be
harmful for the optimization part and at
the end a more theoretical explanation
using the problem of learning menus of
orthogonal functions so let's start with
the piecewise linear curve the
motivation as you edges so before the
motivation is obvious if you want to
understand the free space you can model
it very very nicely using your fish
waste in our hope is if I will let each
one of you to paint the edge of the free
space you will probably use the piece
within our church ok so let's take
forget about the image and everything
and let's just look at a very very
simple problem I give you a
representation of the piecewise linear
curve by just giving you this despising
the excess
and give you a vector of the Y values of
the piecewise linear curve I denote it
by F okay so f 0 s 1 is the value of the
piecewise curve at 0 1 to 2 n minus 1 so
the resolution is n okay and at each one
generic curve can be written if we have
K curve so we need to know the theta R
where are we changing the slope and a R
is the slope at each change of slope
okay so a very very simple problem I
give you f I want you to give me the
parameters of the curve which are a and
theta so it's 2 K numbers they give you
n numbers and you should give me 2 K
numbers there is no image just you know
very very simple much simpler than what
you saw before the success stories of a
of deep learning okay so let's let's
let's see what's going on
so the first right is to use a deep
autoencoder so we will learn one network
which will we will be the encoding
network we call it e of w1 the
architecture is just too dense layers
which value and another dense a dense
layer without value then there is a
decoding back from the 2k number into
the N and we want the square loss we
want it if we apply the encoding and
then the decoding we end up with the
same vector okay and we know that it is
doable
ok so it is possible to express this
piecewise in our curve using these two K
numbers so we can apply it runny and it
doesn't work so well so what you what
you see here on blue is the original
curve on red is after encoding and
decoding and after 500 iteration you see
that it you know looks pretty bad
starts to look better as you perform
more and more iterations but even after
50 thousand iterations it still doesn't
capture
the edges and not very accurate on the
side and this is such a simple task you
would expect that after 50 thousand
iterations you will be able to do
something okay so let's let's think
about the problem and try to do
something better so actually this
problem you can pose it as a convex
optimization problem the following way
so recall we have a vector F and we need
to output the curved parameters let's
think about the vector P sorry this this
is a typo it should be just n
dimensional vector which is all 0
accepted K places that the K places the
max value and the odd max value
represent these two parameter in theta
so we have n values we we look at the
position theta and we put there the
change of the change of slope and then
it is not very difficult to see that we
actually can write a linear relationship
between F between the vector and this
part vectors that represent on zero
represents a change of slope in the
matrix that connect them is a matrix
actually a topic smart with the very
simple matrix the IJ element is just I
minus J plus 1 value ok
so now we can try to learn it using
linear regression and apply SVD for
solving this linear regression problem
ok so the same algorithms which let me
use for deep learning but but but now
the the axe of the network is not very
deep it's just one linear chain yes
you're the nonlinear you give you a
value inside square so this is just for
the definition of W ok but the problem
itself that you need to figure out what
is the value of the inverse of W ok so
we you don't need to learn this
relationship between I and J to W you
just need to every element of the matrix
to find what it is like just like linear
regression ok
the input is s the target is P and you
want to learn the inverse of value which
will W so it's a it's a convex
optimization problem we run it now we
see that it works maybe it is better
than the auto encoder that we saw before
but still even after 50 60 thousand
iterations you can see here that it's
still not perfect okay so now it's a
convex problem we know that it should
converge and it and indeed it will
converge but not after 50 thousand
iterations it needs warrant iteration so
what's going on what's going on is that
the convergence of the path the gradient
descent is governed by the condition
number of W transpose W this matrix so
you can do the calculation we do it in
the paper and the condition of this
matrix grows with the resolution of the
image that we are working on so if we're
working in resolution of n pixels then
you need n to the power of 3.5 at least
n to the power of 3.5 iterations so as
to get a solution which is reasonably
good okay and using more sophisticated
variant of a gradient descent like
Tedder grad or atom will not work
because they perform diagonal
conditioning and here the agonal
conditioning doesn't work okay so what
what can we do so the next step is let's
think about the problem a little bit
more and observe that we can actually
calculate the inverse of W and see that
it's a very simple matrix all of it is
zeros except three numbers which are
just shifted every word every row so
multiplying s by W minus 1 is in fact a
one-dimensional convolution
so now we can pose this problem is
actually learning a single
evolution of three numbers so the
problem become a problem in in three
dimensions okay and it can express still
can express this problem this problem of
finding peaceful signatures so I'm just
trying you this is a very very simple
task and still even though we put it in
three-dimensional space
so now after 15,000 iteration it finally
works okay but after 10,000 iteration it
doesn't work okay so to learn three
numbers we need 50,000 iterations and
you can actually calculate the condition
number of this problem and finite those
you gain something in instead of n to
the power of three point five now it it
is n to the power of three much better
but still lousy okay so it's interesting
to see that when we switch from again
further connected the layer to a
convolutional layer we gain in geometry
not just in sample complexity okay the
geometry of the problem becomes better
okay
but still n to the power of three for
learning three numbers this is
disappointing okay so can we do
something better actually we can if we
think about it as a problem in three
dimension is it's only three dimensions
we can perform for air conditioning but
not diagonal preconditioning but full
preconditioning and if you do this then
the condition number becomes close to
one you can estimate the covariance
matrix very very easily and now things
really works
so now even after five hundred
iterations we are perfect okay so we use
continent because we used convolutions
instead of fully connected we get the
ability to perform preconditioning
efficiently because now we we just need
to precondition a matrix of three by
three and instead of n by n for for a
dense layer so the lesson learned from
this first example first HDD might be
extremely slow
okay even for simple problems and if we
use prior knowledge about the problem it
can help us to choose a better
architecture from the problem and the
better architecture is not used here for
expressible for expressing the problem
better the better architecture is just
used for a better geometry of the
objective and then we can also choose a
better algorithm for a condition that
could be instant instead of just
diagonal dominated for the precondition
of the HDD okay
can't you achieve it with the screw
version attagirl full version of other
bodies that will pull the condition yes
we work perfectly but you cannot do it
on the matrix of n by M this is why you
need to think about the architecture
okay so next next failure flight
activation so activation activation
functions like tango Deepavali or or
sigmoid have a vanishing gradients on
the sides of the other activation and
then they're used in many many
situations for example in there LS PMS
we use a sigmoid gate okay and the
problem is that if we if we look at the
gradient the gradient when you go away
from from the middle of the sigmoid it
just goes to zero okay so let's take a
more extreme a problem and we have this
activation function of say step steps
okay in this function the depicted here
and we just want a single linear layer
okay and then this non linearity of
steps okay so the problem is learning
the mapping from X to the application of
this nonlinear function of steps you
applied on a linear function okay so we
can write it as a an optimization
problem and the problem is that the
gradient no matter what function we will
use here
with this no matter what what network we
will put here the gradient will go to
zero because you is almost everywhere
zero so we cannot apply gradient based
methods directly to this problem so what
can we do so a simple approach is to
smooth this step function using sigmoid
so instead of further steps we'll have
smooth steps ok we call it a u tilde and
this is sometimes work and sometimes it
doesn't work and it depends a lot on the
on the initialization and it's it's a
headache okay so can we do something
else okay so maybe don't use this
function at all just to end-to-end
training find the some architecture
without you at all
that mimic this target that we are
trying to learn so it works but look how
it's you know it's not what we want okay
close to it it's not what we want and
also it's very slow both for tests and
trying time and the curve is not
captured well okay so maybe we can do
something else we can think about this
problem of steps in the multi-class
problem every step is one label okay so
now it works better but it doesn't
capture the boundaries because we simply
throw away all the structures that we
know about this problem by going to
multi class there is no ordering over
labels in multi class okay so again it's
not a good solution
what we can do is to do something which
is very similar to gradual descent but
not with a gladion
so descent but not with a gladion a
function which looks like the gladion so
we call it a forward only back
propagation or forward only layer so the
idea if you look at the objectives it
looks like you applied on wx- you
applied on W star X and then if you take
the gradient you see that you have the
residual term then the gradient the
derivative of U and finally the
derivative of WS which is simply X so
let's throw away this term because it's
a nova
ok so let's throw it away ok it's no
longer bread propagation it's not
gradient and we will use a non gradient
direction the residual time X ok so we
can think about it as a layer where in
the forward path you perform the layer
as is but in the best foot path you just
think that the layer is identity it
sounds like you know a miracle that this
will help but actually there is a truth
and this algorithm is you know a special
case of of the ease of an algorithm of a
Hylian factory and was analyzed
explicitly in casa del tau and you can
actually show that by applying L square
over epsilon for iterations if u is a
Lipchitz then this algorithm actually
converges to the optimal solution even
though it's non convex ok so the lesson
from these to learn is that sometimes
local search word so gradient descent is
simply a local search saying we just
look locally and according to this way
we update our our weights so here is an
example where local search works but not
local search with a gradient local
search with some other direction
so again thinking about about the
problem maybe we can come out
with alternative algorithm that works
better than Radisson yeah it is a scaled
version degree we sometimes give it in
some part of a like hey what what wait
water stain here put the feel like of
the regular price so the gradient is
zero everywhere almost everywhere in
this zone it's not scaling if you know
it is zero I mean the original you it it
easier okay so a very small slope angle
day and then and then but but by what
you scale I mean it's not a constant
scale because if you approximate it by
something smooth then the scale factor
depends on where you are which is
exactly what you're trying to learn so
it's not the constant scale it's a
completely different search direction
okay there it is Kazakh electrons
hydrogen iodide and for ya which skill
the three of that that's true but but
again it's not I mean the point here is
that just you know using tinder flow
that is will know for it let's start by
generating actually Felix plan
activations are desirable or as for
alive activation is desirable because if
for example think about the lsdm you
want the flat activation you want a gate
what is the gate new or one no I mean
the old method of deep learning was to
avoid size parity all right sometimes
you want you want the flatness so the
current trick in deep learning is you
want the flatness you need to avoid the
flatness and then you start bench of
heuristics in order to tune the initial
value of the bias and lsdm right so
maybe you can avoid it by using
different algorithms which are not
valiant face
okay next Raiders okay so there's the
next buzzword that you hear a lot is
end-to-end training okay we didn't do
anything it's all learned by itself okay
this is the line okay we did a lot of
things and at the end we found how it
will work by itself to show it more work
yeah I would like to show you two
approach there are two approaches to
tackling problems one is the end to end
so you forget about all the intermediate
steps and just go to the end and
backdrop everything to all what is
needed and a different approach is
thinking a little bit more about the
problem
the composing it to some subtasks and
trying to put explicit supervision on
subject and what I'm going to show you
here is that so there are many there are
many benefits of n2n okay when you don't
get the extra supervision you can let
you can give the network more freedom
but I want you to see one aspect of
end-to-end learning there are problems
when where if you setup them using end
to end
it will completely fail while if you
decompose and think about the sudden a
little bit more then you can solve it
very very efficiently so here is a
problem the input is a K tuple of images
of random lines
so think about K equals three okay
so you see image like here images like
here there is a single line on the image
and the slope of the line is either
positive or negative okay so it's one of
X for every for every image F 1 of X
determines whether the slope is positive
or negative okay so if I have three
images F 1 of X will be three numbers
okay determining for every image in the
tuple if it is if the slope of the line
in the image is positive or negative
then we pass it into a second function
f2 which returned the parity of the
slope sign okay so it's just parity of
three numbers and and the goal is to
learn the parity of the slopes okay so
let's see how it works the architecture
we took a concatenation of the Linette
architecture and a two-layer value
linked by Sigma at the end-to-end
approach is just to train the overall
network on the primary objective namely
the parity of the three obviously images
of the slopes of the Rakata see images
and the composition approach we just add
a little bit loss on the intermediate
step which is what is the slope of every
image in the tool okay and of course we
also have the loss on the end-to-end
loss on the final prediction of the of
the network but but we guy get by using
additional loss on the intermediate step
so what you see here is a performance of
red and blue red is the end-to-end
approach and blue is a approach with the
composition as a function of K so for K
equals 1 both of them works so for k
equals 2 we see that again both of them
work but it's starting to be harder for
k equal 3 where the composable approach
works still very very good while the
end-to-end approach keeps at a random
chance so with the decomposition
approaches so we have two functions okay
so we build the network the first
Network looks on the three images okay
so the same network applies to the first
image to the second image to the third
image and you get the number of per
image okay and then this
for the donators positive or negative
and then these three numbers enter to a
second network which will give you the
final prediction so in the decomposition
approach you add a loss function on
these three numbers according to the
slope and in the end-to-end experiment
you just have a loss function on the
final prediction supervisor supervised
more exactly you you pay with the
provision you need more power knowledge
of course okay what so that the
immediate idea is to say okay and 2nded
great you need less supervision no prior
knowledge just you know feed it to the
network and everything will work what
you see here is that it actually doesn't
work at all with the end-to-end approach
while if you use the composition with
the same architecture so it's not a
matter of expressiveness of the network
just a matter of optimization okay so
why end-to-end training doesn't work so
there was a similar experiment by paper
by butcher and NGO and they suggest a
local minima a problem for the
end-to-end approach and the composition
approach guides the network toward a
better global minimum instead of a local
minima and we show that this is not a
problem and to I will I will show one
graph here and in the next section I
will elaborate on our explanation so
what we what we think is a problem is a
signal to noise ratio in the gradient
okay so what do I mean by signal to
noise ratio you can calculate the full
gradient of the problem so you take
expectation over the entire space okay
and so the gradient of the true
objective of the generalization error
this is this is this is a real thing
that we want to update based on but we
don't see it we just take either in to
catalyze the descent we take a small
mini batch or in best Latin descent we
still sample a training set and
calculate the gradient on the training
set and
on the true population okay so we can
activate the signal-to-noise ratio the
norm of the gradient as opposed to the
expected value of the difference in norm
between the true gradient and the
estimated blood and intuitively if the
signal to noise ratio is bad then you
will not be able to converge using a
gradient algorithm okay so what you see
here is a is a signal to noise ratio of
end-to-end approach versus the
composition approach to the function of
K so what you see that the signal to
noise drops very fast even for K equals
2 but for K equals 2 this is a very very
small gradient but still above the
precision of say 32-bit float number for
k equal 3 then the signal to noise is
below the precision of a 32-point number
so it means that if you use dental floss
with 32 close numbers then you have no
hope to converge okay so to elaborate on
this last message let's take a more
simplistic approach from well I try to
promote of the sense what M 2 and
training northland because I was there
the claim was a super slow jog around
because you have to do several things
like final decoding in the image and
then either edit actor recognize the
characters and we are several ways in
which we belong
without them together for the work and
the claim was that if after doing this
you stop doing some fine-tuning of
everything and to end it works better I
agree to this claim and the experiment
was not what would you describe because
I didn't train the first Network freeze
it out and then train the second one
then the surprise was that in many cases
it works anyway and but there was a
surprise yeah yeah so it I agree it's
surprising that most of the time
end-to-end works ok or at least in many
times in many practical situations but
you should be aware that if it didn't
work it doesn't think that you have a
problem with the expressiveness of the
of the networks perhaps I should use the
deeper network or these claims maybe it
didn't work because of the optimization
and second just by injecting a little
bit more supervision to the problem
suddenly it we work and I've seen such
things in practice ok so let's let's say
go one step and now do something which
is a bit more theoretically oriented so
the problem is to learn many orthogonal
functions so what do I mean by that so
we have a hypothesis class H and suppose
that it contains many orthonormal
functions and for simplicity's deposit
all the functions that we in the class
that we want to learn are all
orthonormal this means that for every
pair of H H prime in that part of this
class if you take the expectation of H X
H prime X it equal 0 so they are not
correlated ok you can think about it is
the inner product in the function space
between H and H prime ok so we will want
to learn H and because it's the deep
learning error we will do it with the
network ok so you will choose any
architecture parameterised by a vector W
so PW is some function from X
to the real okay and you can choose any
architecture that you want so the
results that we are going to give here
will hold for any architecture so what's
the learning task there is some target
age in the hypothesis class this is a
function that we would like to learn and
what we what we need to do is to
minimize over the weights of the neural
network the objective F sub HW which is
the expected value of some loss function
of the prediction of the network
parameters by W next relatively to the
real target function H of X ok
in Taoism we'll start with a random W
and then updates away based on the
gradient so either by using the gradient
or by using some unbiased estimate of
the class so this is the framework that
we'll consider learning this class of
orthonormal functions using a deep
network architecture and to show that
this is problematic when the size of H
is large the analysis tool will be to
evaluate how much information there is
in the gradient of s HW I want is how
much information about the specific
target function that we are trying to
learn so intuitively if there is not not
a lot of information in the gradient on
the identity of the specific function
that we are trying to learn then
learning will not succeed
ok so what we show is that for every W
and in particular you will start from
some initial random W so it will hope
for your starting point
there are many pairs h h prime of
different function and all our function
to remind you our token also so
functions which are completely different
there is no correlation between these
two functions
and if we look at the gradient of the
objective for the target function being
H relatively to the gradient for the
target function being H prime there's a
difference between these two gradients
goes to zero with the size of the iPad
to describe well X plus one is zero
everywhere when a finite domain this is
this is an example of that this is an
example but but this is a not a very
good example because the number of such
functions is just the dimension what we
will see in a moment is examples where
the number of such function is
exponential in the dimension okay and
then you will not be able to learn it
okay so if if the number of functions in
H is really really large then by
performing the gradient when the target
function is H or H prime you basically
do the same thing okay so there is no
chance that you will be able to converge
to H and not wear H prime okay so this
is the idea so what was the idea of the
proof to prove this theorem we calculate
the variance of the gradient where the
virus is thinking about the uniform
distribution over the functions in H
okay and then we can look at the average
gradient when everything is with respect
to uniform distribution over functions
in H as opposed to a specific function
and taking square Norman expectation so
this is the variance of this gradient
when we average over hypothesis in H and
let's see how it works so intuitively
let's for for simplicity let's think
about the square nose okay so what is
the gradient of F it's the expectation
of the derivative of the square loss so
we have the residual term here and then
it
multiplied by the gradient of T of W
which is specific to the architecture
now if we open it then there is one term
that does not depend on H okay so this
will go out in the calculation of the
variance because it doesn't depend on H
the only thing that depends on H is a
expected value of the function H term
the gradient now if we look at this a
little bit closer fixing some coordinate
of the gradient and allotted by G of X
since our function class is the autonomy
orthonormal functions we can look expand
G using this basis okay so we get a
representation that depends on our
functions plus an orthogonal orthogonal
component and then when we look at the
expected value now with respect to H
because of this decomposition everything
goes down and we end up with the
expected value of G x squared over H so
summing over all the coordinates we will
get the expected value of the gradient
which is usually a constant within here
over the number of functions so this is
a this is the idea of the proof okay so
now let maybe I have one minute so maybe
I will finish and then we'll answer so
an example of such class is the well
known class of parity functions over the
cube of a combinatorial cube where X is
uniformly distribute distributed so
there are two to the D such functions
there are they are all orthonormal so it
means that if for any initial aw there
are many many pairs of parity functions
which are orthonormal while the gradient
between using H or using H prime is
exponentially small it means that you
will not be able to solve it using
floating point calculations now the
result about parity is
whew there were similar how this results
by combining existing results but we
think that this direct approach and
connecting it to deep learning showing
how it couldn't be learned by network
architecture independent of the
architecture is important let me just
finish and then I will take questions to
understand what's going on going on here
let's look at a little bit different
scenarios where we take the class h to
be cost time of inner product between W
and X okay so if we take the target
function in two dimension to be just
something that corresponds to the vector
two - okay and X is uniform distribution
this is how F of W looks like so what
you see here is that there are no non
global minima okay or all the local
minima are also global okay there are
also no saddle points still the slope or
the norm of the gradient almost
everywhere is exponentially small this
is why no local search algorithm will
work for such problems okay and it
doesn't matter what is architecture okay
so let me just wrap up and then we'll
take questions so the cause of failure
optimization can be difficult for
geometric reasons other than local
minima and other points this slide it
can be condition number like we saw in
the piecewise linear problem it can be
flatness like insert activations or
ceiling parity and using bigger or
different networks that will always help
for some problem we can find remedies by
injecting more prior knowledge into the
problem it's just a different way to
encode prior knowledge so for example
convolution can improve the geometry
other than gradient of the tool for
adding adding directly more super
by decomposing the problem and adding
more loss functions understanding the
limitation is very very important I
think there is not enough research on
understanding the limitations deep
learning is really great but in order to
make progress especially in theory but
also in fact is we need to understand
exactly the boundaries of what works
what doesn't work and for more
information you can find the paper on
archive and all the code I promise I'll
be quick about the population with us
see where it takes for every suppose use
a lot of patience pride for which it was
integral T what we hug W is going to be
different there yes in to claim what you
say you should say that they are also
bear hh1 that's almost invisible you are
not distinguishable in two hats rope but
but on the other hand think yeah I
actually completely agree yeah and we
can do it as well but it's more
difficult you need you need the
concentration of measure which shows
that it holds for most every way
so for this apartment problem dates that
long study Nicole community original get
columns of hard imagination is
impossible targets and their the problem
is linear but anything trained with
gradient descent including your network
doesn't seem to be able do it with a
pool for one neuron but not in general
and the thing is in that case the linear
problem and if you switch the algorithm
you can learn and efficiently gradient
based and you just have to go to the
exponential equation was wondering
whether you so exponent so what we prove
here is that exponential gradient will
not work as well it's because the grad
the norm of the gradient itself of two
different target function is not because
because you have a normalization as we
very careful no it's true because I mean
it's true that you cannot do it with a
floating point number okay because the
your knowledge will be larger than the
precision of your life scenario and
because in this harder market or you
take your random matrix you take the
target at the column it was linear
exponential gradient could do it but no
networks some people so it's a problem
where you have an alternate algorithm
you don't keep you have an alternate
going into each other it may be the case
that it's almost orthonormal but not
completely over normal so at one point I
will attempt it okay visual regulation
go into the break and see if you can are
offline and then we got the panel at
forked another difference
[Applause]